AUGUST ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
SUSPENSE HEARING. FIRST NOW AND
IT'S NOT YET THE SUSPENSE
HEARING THIS IS JUST A REGULAR
ORDER HEARING WE WILL DISPATCH
WE WILL DEAL WITH REBELS- AND
THEN WE WILL BREAK BEFORE WE DO
OUR NORMAL SUSPENSE HEARING.
TODAY WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
THE REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS SB
NINE TWENTY TWO SB TEN TWENTY
FOUR AND SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
WILL CONSIDER THE THREE ITEMS
AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND-
CLOSE THE COMMITTEE'S REGULAR
ORDER OF BUSINESS. WE WILL
RETURN AT A- AT THE CALL THE
CHAIR TO DEAL WITH THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR AFTER THE FACT. I DO
NOT SEE A QUORUM AND WE NEED
ONE TO- DEAL WITH THESE ITEMS I
ALSO DO NOT SEE THE SENATOR WHO
NEEDS TO PRESENT. AND WE NEED.
I'LL ROBERT RIVAS IS GONNA
SURPRISE PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
MR WIENER. SO MAYBE MYSTERY
VESTS IF HE'S IN THE BUILDING
CAN COME. HERE HE COMES LIKE
MAGIC. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
OF A NOSE OR SOCIAL DISTANCE
SEEN INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM-
PLEASE WEAR YOUR MASKS WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AVAILABLE ON THE
PHONES TODAY NOT OUTSIDE
BECAUSE THE SMOKE- AND AS WE
HEAR A BAD ITEM ONLY ONE ITEM
WERE ACTUALLY HEARING IN RIGHT
NOW AS A AT. SUBCOMMITTEE AND
THEN WE WILL NEED TO GET UORUM
TO DISPENSE WITH THESE THREE
ITEMS- QUICKLY HAPPENING HERE.
WE WILL START THEN MYSTERY OF
US WILL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF MR WIENER- I DON'T NEED A
MOTION BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET HE IS PRESENTING SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WHEN WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM- IT'LL ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. I AM SORRY
IF YOU CAN HOLD PLEASE WE JUST
RESTARTED QUORUM. SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GONZALEZ
PRESIDENT BIGELOW BURCON LOON.
BONTA CALDERON RIO CHAO DALY
DEEP EGGMAN FONG GABRIEL GARCIA.
THE NORSE QUIRK RIVAS. VOEPEL.
OKAY AND WITH THAT MISTER
WIENER SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE BY DR ED MINUTES SECOND
PAYMENT DR FOR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO SENATE BILL TWO EIGHT
EIGHT IS A NO COST ECONOMIC
STIMULUS THEY'LL JUMP START
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS. THE CENTRAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA RECOVERY FROM COVERT
NINETEEN I KNOW THAT THEIR- I
BELIEVE SPEAKING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY IS QUINN.
LITVAK OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
AND- I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BOOKED THIS IS A LOW COST BILLS
WELL. AT YES MR OPERATOR IS
GLENN ON THE PHONES. STERN
OPERATOR. FOR NOW FOR HAVE AN
OPERATOR. YES LARA SAID SHE
WILL BE HERE BEHALF GO AHEAD.
GREAT IT CAN AFFECTED MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LAURIE POCOCK AND I'M HERE TO
FOR SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL COSPONSORED.
BURKE BEARY COUNCIL AND THE
LOOK ON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR WIENER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS. STATE
AND MACBETH AND THE COMEDY FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE BATTLE OVER
THE YEARS WE'VE SEEN HAVE TO
DATEABLE AND TIME SENSITIVE
PROJECTS ARE OFTEN DELAYED
EXACTLY WHEN WE NEED THEM MOST.
AND I THIRTY THREE OPEN YOUR
THING A MAJOR UPTICK IN DRIVING
AND CONGESTION CALIFORNIANS
WILL INCOME RESIDENTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE UNFAIRLY
SHOULDERING THE IMPACT WITH
LESS ACCESS LONGER TRAVEL TIMES
AND MORE AIR POLLUTION. ALEX
TIME TO DOUBLE DOWN AND BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MAKES
IT SAFE AND CONVENIENT FOR
PEOPLE TO USE ACTIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION. SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE COURT
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY BY
PROVIDING TARGETED EXEMPTION
SIMPLY COOPERATING. COMMONSENSE
PROJECT. I THINK YOU WOULD
EIGHT AT THE COST. FOR THE- AT
THE YOU EIGHTY EIGHT CAN PLAY A
PART MONEY HI AND PUT DOLLARS
PEOPLE TO MARK. EVEN THAT IN
HOW PRESERVE THE ONE POINT SIX
MILLION. TO JOB AND HOW. AND
HAVE BEEN TO HAVE A FIVE TO ONE
AT. OR INTO AND INDIRECT
SPENDING THE BILL UP TO PROVIDE
THE LEVEL OF CERTAINTY PER PROP
THAT MAKE THE MORE COMPETITIVE
FEDERAL FUNDING. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR WEINER AND THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK TO PUT
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION AT
THE CENTER OF CALIFORNIANS
RECOVERY. I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. OKAY I THINK WE
HAVE TESTIMONY INSIDE THE
CHAMBER. MANAGER MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY. ONE ON THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT. OF SB. TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU%
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE'RE LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MANAGER MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF STAMBERG
HERE CARRYING TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY EVAN TURNER COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE INCH
HERE TO JUST BE ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GET THERE MY NUMBER.
AS A REMINDER IF YOU DO WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME IT WILL
WORK TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GRAPPLER GOOD
MORNING- CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARK
WHAT THEM REPRESENTING SAN
DIEGO MTS SERVICE. SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER BINDING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. WITH THAT IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
IN THE CHAMBER THERE ANY
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION THE
PHONES. TWO TWO EIGHT EIGHT. Q.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- S. B. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I'M SHOWING
NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING I'M CHAIR
MEMBERS JULIANA DEROSA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
INDICATES COST OF EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME FOR THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL ADDITIONALLY THERE
RESOURCES BOARD NOTES MINOR
NATURAL COSTS FINALLY- THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE INDICATING A FISCAL
IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEE
NO QUESTIONS OF MR OF US WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT
WHEREAS WHEN I VOTE MANAGER.
THANK YOU. CHECK IT OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MISS BARRICADE
HAND VOTING NO IN MISTER
BIGELOW OF ANY NOW. CURRENT IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE STRANGEST
ROLL CALL VOTE EVER BUT WILL.
FREEDOM OF THAT WAY. WITH THAT
WE WILL THE TWO REMAINING
ITEMS- THE AUTHORS HAVE WAVE
PRESENTATION- SO S. B. ONE
THREE FIVE ONE AND S. B. TEN
TWENTY FOUR WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE- COUNTER TO BE
DISPENSED OF LATER TODAY- IS
THERE WITH THAT. IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO EITHER
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF EITHER OF THOSE TWO ITEMS-
YOU CAN ONLY REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WE ARE
NOT TAKING TESTIMONY BECAUSE
PRESENTATION HAS BEEN WAIVED WE
WILL FIRST GO TO THE PHONES IF
ANYBODY IS THERE TO. REGISTER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO SB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE OR SB TEN
TWENTY FOUR. OPERATOR. WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE IN CURING BE ONE
MOMENT ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF EITHER OF THESE
GIRLS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. JUST ONE MOMENT
HERE FIRST ONE. I WILL WRITE A
LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CAME
THE BAR JUNIOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT AT THE
TEN TWENTY FOUR JUN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT I HAVE TO MARIN Q. WE'RE
JUST GIVING LINE NUMBERS NOW.
HOME. OVERLYING TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JAMES DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
JOBS IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ENACT FORTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE WALL- ON BEHALF OF EFFORTS
FORTY HUNDRED PLUS RETAIL
MEMBERS AMERICAN PATROL IN THE
CONVENIENCE OF THE LOCATION
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
I HAVE NO FURTHER WIND THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE THE GALLERY THAT
LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO EITHER THOSE
BILLS. C. NINE WITH THAT. I
BELIEVE WHAT WE WILL DO IS
RECESS- UNTIL. THE CALL OF THE
CHAIR SO WE HAVE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED QUORUM FOR OUR-
LARGER SUSPENSE MEETING THAT IF
PEOPLE WANT TO FIGHT GO BACK TO
THEIR OFFICES PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO- WE NEED THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN AND TO START THEIR
MEETING AS WELL AND THAT'S WHEN
WE WILL BEGIN OUR.
READY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND WELCOME
BACK. WE ARE NOW GOING TO TURN
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE
FILE. BEFORE WE START WITH THE
EIGHTY NINE BILLS ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND OF COURSE THE REPUBLICAN
STAFF. FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO PROBLEMS. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF OF
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE OF COURSE
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANT'S OFFICE
IN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PERSONNEL AND THE MANY OTHERS
WHO HELPED ENSURE THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS CONTINUES
DURING VERY TRYING TIMES. I
LIKE TO THINK MY VICE CHAIR WHO
I KNOW IS HERE. FIRST
COOPERATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER BIGELOW AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- FOR BEING SO DILIGENT
READING THROUGH THE BILLS AND
GETTING BACK TO US SO QUICKLY
UNBOUNCE. THANK YOU. IT'S NOW
TIME DISPENSED WITH THE NINETY
BILLS ON THE SUSPENSE FILE
AGREE BY ONE IN MY TALKING
POINTS IN TWO MINUTES. I
BELIEVE IT'S NINETY BILLS. NOT.
EIGHTY NINE. I'D LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THE HEARING
AGENDA IS ORGANIZED
ALPHABETICALLY BY AUTHOR AND IS
AVAILABLE ONLINE AT ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES
WEBSITE WHICH IS LOCATED AT
EIGHT P. R. O. DOT ASSEMBLY.
DOT CA DOT GLV. I'M GONNA GIVE
MEMBERS A TIME TO PULL UP THAT
WEBSITE AS WELL WE'RE NOT
DISTRIBUTING PAPER COPIES TODAY
SO IF YOU WANT TO FOLLOW ALONG.
I PROMISE I WILL GO SLOW ENOUGH
YOU CAN FOLLOW ALONG AT EIGHT
P. R. O. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOP. LATER THIS AFTERNOON
FOLLOWING TODAY'S HEARING THE
COMMITTEE WILL POST THE RESULTS
OF THE SUSPENSE FILE HEARING.
ON THAT SAME WEBSITE. MISTER
BIGELOW IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAY BEFORE WE
GET STARTED. I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO THANK- YOURSELF AND THE
STAFF ON BOTH SIDES- FOR
WORKING SO COOPERATIVELY AND-
HELPING EACH OF US TO COME TO.
A PLACE WHERE WE CAN MAKE THESE
DECISIONS THAT. AFFECTS SO MANY
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO ALL OF THEM AND I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST THANK
THE STAFF IN THE BUILDING AS A
WHOLE. FROM FROM EVERYONE THAT
DOES THE SIMPLEST OF TASKS TO
THE MOST COMPLICATED I WANT TO
THANK THEM BECAUSE THIS IS A
TRYING TIME AND IT IS REALLY.
DIFFICULT AND FOR THOSE THAT
ARE LISTENING AND PAYING
ATTENTION WE ARE GOING THROUGH
A SERIES OF WILDFIRES AND
DIFFICULT DAYS RIGHT NOW AND
CERTAINLY YESTERDAY WAS ONE OF
THOSE FOR. FOR A- A CORPORATE
ASSET THAT WAS ASSISTING ON A
FIRE AND WE LOST TO. A
GENTLEMAN WHO WAS FLYING A
HELICOPTER DROPPING WATER AND
FIRE AND WE WANT TO THINK OF
HIM AND- HIS FAMILY- IN IN THIS
LOSS SO. WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT
THERE WORKING SO HARD AND I
WANT TO THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
DOING WHAT THEY DID
COOPERATIVELY WORKING TO
RELOCATE. N. AND FOLLOWING THE
INSTRUCTIONS SO THANK YOU TO
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE ABLE TO
LISTEN AND LET'S JUST REMEMBER
THAT IN IN OUR THOUGHTS THOSE
FOLKS. THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. ABSOLUTELY AND THESE ARE
TRYING TIMES OBVIOUSLY EVERY
DAY WORK LEUCINE- MORE
INDIVIDUALS TO THE COVE IT
CRISIS. AND ON TOP OF THAT
THESE WILDFIRES WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN A LOSS OF LIFE. I KNOW. WE
SAW A LOT OF PEOPLE DISPLACED
FROM THEIR HOMES. POURING INTO
DOWNTOWN- LAST NIGHT TODAY. AT
AND- OBVIOUSLY THE AIR QUALITY
OF SACRAMENTO WE ALL. ARE
FEELING THE FIRES AND IN A
SENSE SOUTH- OUR HEARTS GO OUT
TO. EVERYBODY AFFECTED BY ALL
OF THESE. EMERGENCIES THEY WERE
FACING IN THE STATE. AGAIN THE
WEBSITE TO FOLLOW. IS A P. R.
O. DOT ASSEMBLY. DOT CA DOT GLV.
WILL BE GOING IN ALPHABETICAL
ORDER. THE FIRST BILL BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE. IS GOING TO BE
SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
ALAN. IT'S A BILL REGARDING C.
CLASS. I WOULD NEED A MOTION
THE MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK. AND
A SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON. SB
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN BY MR ALLEN
SEQUIN FIREMEN ALL LEADERSHIP
PROJECTS. THAT'S A DO PASS. ON
IN  ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL SUBSTITUTE
THE MOTION AND SECOND FOR ALL
DO PASS OR DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS ON THE REST OF THE
SUSPENSE FILED TODAY. THE NEXT
BILL IS SENATE BILL TEN FORTY
FOUR. BY SENATOR BEN ALLEN.
IT'S A BILL PERTAINING TO
FIREFIGHTERS. THAT IS A DO PASS
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO.
FIRST AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND LOCALS TO ENFORCE
THE BILL INSTEAD OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. SECOND PROVIDE
MORE TIME FOR AIRPORTS TO
TRANSITION AFTER FEDERAL LAW
CHANGES. THREE ADDRESS TIME
FRAMES AND ADD NOTIFICATIONS
AND FOR CONDITION CAL E. P.
A.'S DUTIES ON AVAILABLE
RESOURCES. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. THAT CONCLUDES MR
ALLAN'S BILLS BEFORE US. WILL
NOW MOVE TO MR ARCHULETA. SB
EIGHT NINETY FIVE. BY SENATOR
BOB ARCHULETA. THIS IS A BILL
PERTAINING TO ZERO EMISSIONS
FUELS AND INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS
GETS OUT DO PASSED ON IN A ROLL
CALL. THE NEXT BILL IS SB.
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX. THE BILL BY
SENATOR BOB ARCHULETA. THE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL IS BATTERY
DISPOSAL. THIS IS A DO PASS
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ADD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO THE LIST
OF WASTE ACILITY OPERATORS AND
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO USE
AND UPDATE EXISTING LOCAL
PROTOCOLS. I GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. THAT CONCLUDES MR ARCH
LET AS. BILLS IN FRONT OF US.
WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO S. B. AND
THEN. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PRO TEM SPELLS.
MISS ATKINS SB NINE NINETY FIVE
BY SENATOR ATKINS. IT IS A
SEQUEL A BILL AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP ACT.
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW EL PR TO
ADOPT AN APPLICANT FI. WE ARE
ADDING THIS APPLICANT BE IN THE
SAME WAY WE INCLUDED THE FEET
IN THE ASSEMBLY VERSION AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP AT
EXTENSION AB TWO NINE NINE ONE
SANTIAGO IT IS TO. ENSURE
EQUITY. SB ELEVEN TWENTY BY
SENATOR ATKINS. THIS IS A
HOUSING BILLS DEALING WITH
DUPLEXES AND LOT SPLITS. THAT
IS THE DO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. WITH MATH BARRICADE HAM
MISTER BLOOM AND PETRIE-NORRIS
NOT VOTING. THAT CONCLUDES A
PRO TEM'S BILLS BEFORE OUR
COMMITTEE. I'M SORRY BEFORE
MOVING ON TO BE I'M GONNA JUST
TAKE A QUICK BREAK WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RECESS I JUST NEED
SOME WATER. I'M SORRY.
WHEN THE
DALLAS.
WE'RE GOOD. OKAY SO WE
HAVE GOTTEN THROUGH ALL OF THE
AS. MAYBE IN ON TO SENATORS
WITH THE LAST NAMES STARTING
WITH THE B. B. LIKE WELL. SB.
NINE THIRTY FOUR. BY MISSTATES
SENATOR BATES THIS IS A BILL
PERTAINING TO NONPROFIT FILING
FEES. SHE SHE WAS PREVIOUSLY
THE MINORITY LEADER YES SB NINE
THIRTY FOUR BY MISS BATES GETS
OUT ON ENABLE CALL. S. B. BUT
THAT THAT CONCLUDES MISS BATES
BILLS. IN FRONT OF US. THE NEXT
AUTHOR IS MISTER BELL. SB SEVEN
NINETY FIVE. BARBELL THE
SUBJECT IS HOUSING. AND THAT
WILL BE HELD IN COMMITTEE. THE
NEXT BILL IS SB. EIGHT ZERO
THREE ALSO BY SENATOR BELL.
THIS PERTAINS TO PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES. THIS BILL GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO ALLOW D. H. C. S. TO
DELEGATE DUTIES TO COUNTIES AND
TO ADD FUNDING PROVISIONS. OUR
NEXT BILL IS SB. NINE ONE TWO.
THIS IS ALSO BY SENATOR BILL
BELL. THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
FOSTER CARE. THIS GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO DELETE THE PROVISIONS
REGARDING TO EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS
AND REDUCE FUTURE MERGING SEA
AID TO SIX MONTHS THAT'S OUR
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS. OUR NEXT
BILL IS ALSO BY SENATOR BILL.
IT IS S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE.
THIS BILL IS READ WITH REGARD
TO TRANSPORTATION BONDS. DO YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
BONDING AUTHORITY TO A
PRINCIPAL AMOUNT NO MORE THAN
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN TO MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
THAT CONCLUDES SENATOR BELLS
BILLS IN FRONT OF OUR ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. SB TWO ZERO THREE
CENTER BRADFORD'S FIRST BILL.
IT DEALS WITH INTERROGATIONS.
THE MINERS TO PASS. ONE OF THE
ROLL CALL. THAT CONCLUDES
SENATOR BRADFORD'S BILLS IN
FRONT OF OUR COMMITTEE. AND
CONCLUDES ALL SENATORS STARTING
WITH B. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
SENATORS STARTING WITH THE
LETTER C. THE FIRST BILL IS
FROM SENATOR COPY AT ALL. IT IS
SB FOUR FOURTEEN. THE SUBJECT
OF THE BILL IS SMALL SYSTEM
WATER AUTHORITIES. THAT BILL IS
HELD IN COMMITTEE. SORRY. OUR
NEXT BILL IS SB. FOURTEEN ZERO
NINE. THAT IS BY SENATOR COPY
ADAM. THIS BILL PERTAINS TO A
CAL E. I. T. C. REPORT. THIS
BILL PASSES WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB.
FOURTEEN TEN. IS A BILL BY
MISCARRY ADAM. THIS BILL HAS TO
DO WITH TENANCIES AND LAMB. AND
TAX BREAKS. THIS BILL IS HELD
IN COMMITTEE. SB. FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE IS ALSO BY CENTER
CABALLERO. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE STATE ROUTE ONE EIGHTY
THREE. IT IS A DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. THAT CONCLUDES
SENATOR HAVING ATAS BILLS IN
FRONT OF THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. OKAY
WE'R NOW IN SB NINE TWENTY
TALK KILL BY SENATOR CHIANG
LING LING CHANG THIS DEALS WITH
COMPUTER CRIMES THAT BILL WILL
BE HELD IN COMMITTEE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR SENATORS
BEGINNING WITH THE LETTER C. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE LETTER
D. SB NINE TWENTY ONE. THIS IS
BY SENATOR DOLLY. THE DAILY OR
DOLLY. DALY I GOT IT RIGHT.
DILLY DALLY. THE WORST HALF OF
THE TALLIES. JUST CHECKING AS
IT PERTAINS TO STATE ROUTE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR. IT IS A DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. S. B. NINE
EIGHTY NINE BY CENTER DALLY
RETAINS TO THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY THAT BILL IS HELD
IN COMMITTEE. WE'LL NOW MOVE
FROM CENTER TO DALLY TO SENATOR
DODD. S. B. TWO FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD. THIS PERTAINS TO
MEDIC CAL TRANSITION PROGRAM.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
THE CONTENTS AND INSTEAD
AUTHORIZE A NEW TEMPORARY
TRANSITION PROGRAM. THAT GETS
OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. OUR NEXT BILL IS SB
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
DODD. THIS PERTAINS TO POWER
SHUT OFFS AT BILLS HELD IN
COMMITTEE. I'M SORRY. F. R.
NEXT BILL IS AT S. B. ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN IT IS ALSO BY
SENATOR DODD THIS BILL PERTAINS
TO NURSE MIDWIVES. THIS BILL.
PASSES AS AMENDED TO MODIFY
DATA COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS
BACK IT'S OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. THAT
CONCLUDES MR DODDS. BILLS IN
FRONT OF US TODAY. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON. I'M SORRY.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW TAKE A
RECESS. YOU'RE WELCOME TO GO
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE AND- JUST
WATCHED TO SEE WHEN WE COME
BACK ON. THANK YOU.
WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WE'LL PROCEED WE WERE
ON DIS- AND I THINK THIS IS OUR
LAST TEAM ANOTHER BODY OTHER
THAN ACTED ALSO. STARTING WITH
ASSEMBLY I'M SORRY SENATE BILL
NINE. SENATE BILL NINE DEALS
WITH SURPLUS PROPERTY. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
PASADENA IN SOUTH PASADENA AND
MAKE OTHER CHANGES BACK IT'S
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. S. B.
EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR DID ALSO.
A PESTICIDE QUARTERLY REPORT.
THAT IS DO YOU PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. S. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN
BY CENTER DID AWESOME THIS
DEALS WITH DETENTION FACILITIES.
THIS GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
AS AMENDED TO ADD FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS. OUR NEXT BILL IS
SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR DID AWESOME. THIS IS A
BILL PERTAINING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL AS AMENDED TO
REDUCE THE PENALTY TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND MAKE OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES. THE
NEXT BILL. IS SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN ALSO BY CENTER DRIVE SO.
THIS BILL DEALS WITH WORKER
SAFETY STANDARDS. DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE SPECIFIED
GROUPS OF WORKERS INCLUDING HSS
PROVIDERS FROM THE BILL THAT
GETS OUT IN THE B. ROLL CALL.
AS OUR AUTHORS AMENDMENTS. SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE BY CENTER
DEVICE SO THIS DEALS WITH
WORKER PROTECTIONS. DO YOU PASS
AS AMENDED TO CLEAR RIFAI A
CHAIN LIABILITY IN OTHER
PROVISIONS IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. PACKETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. THAT CONCLUDES THE
DIS AND CENTERED ASOS HILLS
BETWEEN BORIS TODAY. APPARENTLY
THERE ARE NO SENATORS WITH THE
E. OR F. BUT WITH NO BILLS
DON'T. HAVE TO THINK THROUGH
THAT ONE. SO WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON. TO THE JEEZ. SENATOR
GALGIANI. SB ONE SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR DECKED OUT YANNI
DEALING WITH HYPERTENSION TASK
FORCE. THE BILL'S HELD IN
COMMITTEE. SB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GALGIANI. THIS
DEALS WITH MISSING PERSONS
REPORT PACKETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR GALGIANI. THIS DEALS
WITH CANNABIS FOR ANIMALS THIS
ONE IS HELD IN COMMITTEE. SB
SEVEN FORTY ONE BY GALGIANI
THIS DEALS WITH VITAL RECORDS.
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE SECTIONS RELATED TO
VITAL RECORDS FEES BACK IT'S
OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL. MOVING
ON NOW TO SENATOR GONZALEZ SB
ELEVEN THIRTY BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THIS DEALS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. IT IS S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY. THE RIVER. I IT IS SO
IT IS ON SOME PAPERWORK BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO USE HER FULL NAME
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE SAME LAST
NAME AND THE SAME FIRST INITIAL
HER FULL NAME SHOWS UP AS LENA
AND SO IT IS BEEN MISPLACED
UNDER THE AISLES. BUT IN FACT
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN UNDER THE
JEEZ. STOP. VERY SIMILAR NAMES
JUST THE- ARE IS DIFFERENT.
SAME INITIALS YEAH WE'RE NOT
RELATED THE. OKAY SB ELEVEN
THIRTY BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. THE
SUBJECT IS A CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND. DO
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
PROGRAM GOALS MUST BE ACHIEVED
WITH EXISTING RESOURCES. AND
STATE THAT THE C. P. U. C. MAY
NOT EXCEED THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. NEXT
WE MOVE ON TO THE AGES.
STARTING WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SB THREE FIFTEEN I SENATOR
HERTZBERG THIS DEALS WITH COURT
PROGRAMS THAT BILLS HELD IN
COMMITTEE. NEXT WE HAVE SB
THREE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THIS DEALS WITH
MISLEADING ADVERTISEMENT. DO
YOU ARE MISLEADING ADVERTISING
DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE SB THREE SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL IS THE RE
ENTRY COMMISSION. THIS BILL ON
A ROLL CALL IS PASSED OUT AS
AMENDED TO MAKE THE COMMISSION
SUBJECT TO A FUTURE
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. NEXT WE HAVE SB
TEN SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THIS DEALS WITH
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE. THIS BILL
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AS
AMENDED TO RETAIN ONLY THE
LIMITATION OF THE ASSET TEST
AND OTHER NON FISCAL PROVISIONS.
NEXT WE MOVE ON TO SENATOR HILL.
SENATOR HILL HAS SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THIS DEALS WITH
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS. THIS
BILL GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
WITH NO AMENDMENTS. NEXT WE
HAVE S. B. EIGHT SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR HELL. THIS BILL IS IN
REGARD TO THE DIG SAFE PROGRAM.
THIS GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO
SPECIFIED NOTIFICATION TIME
FRAMES IT MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. NEXT WE HAVE SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE. BY SENATOR HILL.
THIS DEALS WITH THE WORKERS
COMP PRESUMPTION. THIS GETS OUT
ON AB ROLL CALL. NEXT WE HAVE
SB.SIX SIXTY SEVEN. THIS IS BY
SENATOR WESSEL. THE SUBJECT IS
RECYCLING. DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE ALL PROVISIONS EXCEPT
THE FIVE YEAR. ASSESSMENT
TICKETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE SB THIRTEEN OH ONE
BY SENATOR WEST SO. THIS
PERTAINS TO THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY. THE TIJUANA RIVER. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO RECAST
REVISED THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL THIS GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO HER TADO THIS IS
NOT AN OFFICIAL RECESS I JUST
NEED TO CHECK SOMETHING. BEFORE
WE READ THE SOUTH.
ALL RIGHT.
SB FIVE FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
TADO. WITH REGARD TO THE FRANK
KERN CANAL. DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO CREATE A STUDY ON
THE FRONT KERN NOW THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB TEN
TWELVE BY CENTER TADO THIS
DEALS WITH TITLE IN ABANDONED
WELLS. TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. S. B. ELEVEN OH THREE-
TADA THIS DEALS WITH SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES HOLD IN COMMITTEE. SB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
TADA THIS DEALS WITH SSI S. S.
P. TASK FORCE HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR TADO THIS DEALS WITH
CAL WORKS. DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO STRIKE SECTION TWO OF THE
BILL THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGES.
THERE'S NO SENATOR WITH A
LETTER I. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
J. BEGINNING WITH SENATOR
JACKSON. SB FOUR NINETY THREE.
BY SENATOR JACKSON. THIS DEALS
WITH CAMPUS SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
REPLACE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
CLARIFY TITLE NINE INTERACTIONS
AND OTHER AMENDMENTS BACK IT'S
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. NEXT WE
HAVE S. B. NINE SEVENTY THREE.
I SENATOR JACKSON. THIS DEALS
WITH EMPLOYER PAID DATA. DO YOU
PASS WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
SB TWELVE OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
JACKSON. THIS DEALS WITH BACKUP
POWER. DO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. OUR NEXT BILL IS SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE JACKSON.
THIS PERTAINS TO. UNPAID BUT
PROTECTED FAMILY LEAVE. THIS
PASSES ON A . ROLL CALL I
REALIZED EARLIER I NOTED THAT
MEMBERS WHO WORK OFF OF BILLS
ON A B. ROLL CALL BECAUSE THEY
TO STICKY HERE AND I DON'T
NORMALLY DO THAT TO THE END IT
BECOMES PUBLIC INFORMATION. I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE MEMBERS WHO
ARE OFF THIS BILL- THAT WILL
BECOME PUBLIC INFORMATION I'M
NOT GONNA HI I JUST HAPPEN TO
KNOW THAT MY MIND AND SO I
REALIZED I HAD MISTAKENLY READ.
THE PREVIOUS ONES- BUT WE WILL
NOT BE DOING THAT. IT STILL
PASSES ON THE ROLE. S. B. THAT
CONCLUDES. SENATOR JACKSON'S
BILLS IN FRONT OF THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO THANK
SENATE JACKSON FOR HER LONG
HISTORY OF PUTTING A LOT OF
BILLS AND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS HAS BEEN- QUITE
A FEAT. OF BILLS ANNA IT IS
QUITE AMAZING WHAT SHE HAS DONE
WITH HER LEGACY AND IN THE
SENATE. IT'S HER LAST YEAR TO
LAST TIME BEFORE US. WHAT A
BILLS I'M SURE. SELL WITHOUT
WILL MOVE ON TO. SENATOR JONES
SB TEN TWENTY FOUR. THIS DEALS
WITH HOT OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES.
DO PASSES AMENDED. TO STATE THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THE BILL'S PROGRAM WILL RESULT
IN THE REGISTRATION AND USE ON
PUBLIC LANDS OF A VERY SMALL
NUMBER OF COMPETITION H. FEES.
SUNSET THE PROGRAM AS OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. REQUIRE A REPORT IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ON THE NUMBER OF
NON COMPLIANCE- H. FEES
REGISTERED EACH YEAR AND ON
CITATIONS IN OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS AGAINST ILLEGAL USE OF
EACH FEES ON PUBLIC LANDS.
ESTABLISH THE SPECIAL FEE
APPLICABLE TO NON COMPLIANT- H.
FEES AT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX DOLLARS. PLUS AN AMOUNT AS
DETERMINED BY DMV TO ENSURE DMV
RECAPS THE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PROGRAMMING COST WITHIN THE
LIFETIME OF THE PROGRAM. AND
SPECIFIED ENFORCEMENT AS
ELIGIBLE USE OF THE FEE REVENUE.
CRACKERZ OUT HOLD ON.
I'M GONNA
RETRACT MY STATEMENT THAT THAT
GOT OUT WE'RE GOING TO PAN BATS
AS I AM NOT SURE WE HAVE THE
VOTES TO GET THAT BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE. SO AGAIN FOR THOSE
WATCHING- IT WAS A LOT OF WORK
HAS BEEN DONE ON THIS BILL OVER
THE LAST DAY- AND AS A RESULT
WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS WHAT
pMAY OR MAY NOT BE THERE AND WE
WILL. EITHER PASS THE BILL AS
AMENDED OR HOLD IT DEPENDING ON
THE FENCE BUT WE'RE NOT TAKING
A RECESS. ALL THE PEOPLE. RIGHT.
OKAY ALL.
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
GOOD ONES COMMON ALL RIGHT I
THINK WE FIGURED THAT OUT. I'LL
JUST SAY THIS I WANT TO THANK-
I THINK THE REPUBLICAN STAFF
REPUBLICANS FOR WORKING WITH US
AS BECAUSE OF KIND OF THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN WE'RE
DEALING WITH. TRYING TO- FIGURE
THINGS OUT A LITTLE LATER THAN
WE'D LIKE TO. AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT AND WE WERE TRYING TO
WORK WITH SENATOR JOHNS FOR.
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME- TO
GET THIS RIGHT SO. THANK YOU
FOR THE COOPERATION. OF THE
SENATE STAFF AND SENATORS AND
THAT GETS OUT RIGHT I MEAN THAT
REPUBLICAN STAFF AND-
REPUBLICANS ON THE COMMITTEE
AND THAT GETS OUT SB TEN TWENTY
FOUR WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS. GET
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. WILL NOW
MOVE ON. TO MISTER MCGUIRE SO
WE FINISH THE JAYS. THERE'S NO
CASE. ELS I NEVER NOTICED
BEFORE THE BILL WAS EXAMPLES OF.
LEENA CONSULT WITH. FORTY FOUR
EIGHT. SB FOUR THIRTY ONE. BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THIS IS A BILL
TO DEAL WITH TELECOMMUNICATIONS
THAT IS HELD IN COMMITTEE. S.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THIS IS A
CONTRACTOR LICENSING BILL. DO
YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL. S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
PREPAID MOBILE. DO YOU PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE ON TO SENATOR MITCHELL.
STARTING WITH S. B. FIVE FIFTY
FIVE. THIS DEALS WITH COUNTY
JAILS. DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED
TO CAP THE COST OF PHONE AND
VIDEO CALLS AND COMMITS
COMMISSARY ITEMS THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR MINING.
THIS DEALS WITH HEALTH CARE
TRANSACTIONS. DO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. ANOTHER MEMBER WILL
MESS AS HE MOVES ON AND RETIRES
FROM THE SENATE. A CENTER
MINING'S LAST BILLING ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS. THIRTEEN POINT
BILL. WE WILL NOW MOVE FROM THE
ADDAMS. THERE ARE NO ENDS OR
OWES. AND ARE AT LEAST ON HERE
SOME IS GONNA TEXT ME THEM
WRONG RIGHT SO WE MOVE ON TO
THE PEAS. SENATOR PAM. SB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR PAN
DEALS WITH PP STOCKPILES. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
SIX MONTHS STOCKPILE FOR
HOSPITALS AND SPECIFIED
EMPLOYERS. TO CHANGE THE
STOCKPILE TO SIXTY DAYS OF
SURGE CAPACITY FOR OTHER
EMPLOYER. TO CLARIFY THE
PROCESS TO DEFINE STOCKPILE
REQUIREMENT AND TO MAKE OTHER
CHANGES. LET'S GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. NEXT WE HAVE S. B.
FOUR ZERO SIX BY DR PAN. THIS
IS THE HEALTH CARE OMNIBUS BILL.
DO PASSED AS AMENDED ON A ROLL
CALL. TO INSERT A TECHNICAL
CHANGE RELATED TO BACKGROUND
CHECKS CODIFY FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES.
AGAIN I GOT OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THE NEXT BILL IS S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR PAM. THIS
DEALS WITH PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO MODIFY
THE REPORTS AND THE PROGRAM
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE SB. SEVEN TWENTY
NINE. BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
SENATOR PORTANTINO'S SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE DEALS WITH SICK
LEAVE DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
LINE PROVISIONS TO THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. OUR NEXT
BILL IS SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THAT DEALS
WITH HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
PLANNING. DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE REPORT IN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND CHANGE THE
SEISMIC COMPLIANCE DEADLINE TO
TWENTY THIRTY TWO. BACK IT'S
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB NINE
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
THIS DEALS WITH FIREARMS DO YOU
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THIS DEALS WITH
RETAIL SITES. DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADD LABOR PROVISIONS
CLARIFY THE PAYMENT SCHEDULE
AND MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES. BUT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE OURS WE'RE GONA NEED TO
TAKE A SHORT BREAK A SHORT
RECESS YOU'RE WELCOME TO GO
BACK TO YOUR- NOT SURE HOW LONG
IT'LL BE BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
SHORT RECESS.
OKAY AND WHAT'S
TAX HI HOW. IRATE WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK NOW. SEE WHERE WE
WERE. YUP. YEP WE'RE ON OURS.
OUR SENATORS THAT BEGIN WITH
THE LETTER R. STARTING WITH.
SENATOR RUBIO. SUSAN RUBIO. THE
YOUNGER SISTER. UNLIKE THE
GONZALEZ IS THEY ACTUALLY ARE
SISTERS. SENATOR RUBIO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH SB TWO NINETY
TWO. BY SENATOR RUBIO. THIS IS
A BILL DEALING WITH INSURANCE
AND WILDFIRE RISK. AS THE
SENATE DID WE'RE GOING TO
AMENDED THIS BILL- AS THEY DID
TO THE COMPANION PIECE AND
CREATE A STUDY ON FIRE
INSURANCE IN WILDFIRE RISK.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
OTHER PROVISIONS THE BILL WOULD
BE STRUCK. SB SIX FOURTEEN BY
RUBIO THIS IS A READING
ASSESSMENT. THAT ONE IS HELD IN
COMMITTEE. WE'RE MOVING ON NOW.
TO THE **** WITH SENATOR
SKINNER. WE'LL BE STARTING WITH
SB THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR
SKINNER. THIS IS AN EBT TASK
FORCE. HOLDEN COMMITTEE. NEXT
WE HAVE SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER. THIS DEALS
WITH PEACE OFFICER RECORDS. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND REMOVE
LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
A
FINISH OF SCANNERS AND THEN I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
A BREAK. SB NINE SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR SKINNER. THIS DEALS
WITH CORPORATE TAXES DO YOU
PASS ONE OF B. ROLL CALL. S. B.
TEN SIXTY FOUR SKINNER. THIS
DEALS WITH PRISON INFORMANTS DO
PASSED AS AMENDEDTO ACCEPT THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT GETS
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. SB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE SKINNER. THIS DEALS
WITH DENSITY BONUSES DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO DELETE THE FEE
PROVISIONS AND MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO SENATOR STERN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A SMALL
BREAK.
YEAH I POSTED.
WHAT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
POWER THROUGH THESE REMAINING
BILLS. BEFORE WE START I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT WHAT A GREAT
JOB WE DID- DESPITE. ALL OF THE
CHALLENGES WE FACED WE ENSURED
THAT EVERY. BODY POSSIBLE COULD
GO HOME WITH THE BILL. HARD
WHEN YOU HAVE CUT YOUR OWN
BILLS EXTENSIVELY AND. I SHOULD
SAY THAT SOMETIMES OCCUR
REPUBLICAN BILLS BUT- YOU KNOW.
WE DID GOOD. WE GET OUR BEST.
ALL RIGHT SB FIVE NINETY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN. THIS DEALS WITH
I. HSS. DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE I. HSS RECIPIENTS TO
MAKE THE BILL A COUNTY OPTION.
SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
STERN FELT MY VOTE BY MAIL I'M
SORRY THE LAST ONE GOT OUT I AM
ON A ROLL CALL. THAT WAS ON SB
FIVE NINETY SIX. SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR STERN.
IS VOTE BY MAIL I GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY SENATOR STERN THIS
DEALS WITH THE ANIMAL
PROTECTION. DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MODIFY
THE GRANDFATHER CLAUSE AND
REQUIRE THE DIRECTOR AT THE F.
W. TO MAKE A FINDING BEFORE
SUSPENDING THE ABILITY TO
IMPORT AN EXOTIC ANIMAL DURING
A PANDEMIC. THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY BY SENATOR STERN. THIS
DEALS WITH CLIMATE CHANGE TO
PASS WITHOUT THERE'S IMMENSE
AND THAT GETS OUT ON THE B.
ROLL CALL. SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR STERN. THIS
DEALS WITH FIRE PROTECTION. DO
PASSED WITHOUT THERE'S
AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE THE DATA
BACK BAY SECTION EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON THE FORCE RESOURCE
IMPROVEMENT GRANTS AND INCLUDE
EDUCATION AS AN ELIGIBLE
EXPENDITURE. BUT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. WE WILL NOW MOVE.
TO THE USE WE ARE DONE WITH THE
**** INDIA WITH SENATOR BURKE.
SB SIX SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR
UMBERG. M. H. S. A. THAT'S WHAT
IT DEALS WITH AND IT IS A
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB NINE
EIGHTY BY SENATOR AMBERG.
DEALING WITH GENETIC TESTING.
DO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY
SENATOR ON BURKE DEALING WITH
PRICE GOUGING. TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB TWELVE TWENTY BY
SENATOR UMBERG ILLINGWORTH
RADIALIS. DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. WE'RE FINISHED WITH
SENATOR- BERGEN WE WILL MOVE ON
TO SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI. SB
NINE OH EIGHT BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY DEALING WITH DEBT
COLLECTORS TO PASS A TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS SECOND THOUGHT ON A
B. ROLL CALL.
SB. ONE FORTY
FIVE. I'M SORRY. SB BY SENATOR
WIENER SB ONE FORTY FIVE
DEALING WITH THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SB FIVE NINETY TWO
SENATOR WIENER. THAT DEALS WITH
JURY SERVICE. DO PASSED S
AMENDED TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
BY SENATOR WIENER. THAT DEALS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY PROVISIONS
RELATED TO OUT OF NETWORK
SERVICE MEDICAL NECESSITY AND
PROVIDERS. BOB GETS OUT WITH
THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB
NINE OH TWO BY SENATOR UITM
DEALING WITH HOUSING HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER
EMERGENCY SHELTERS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE CLEAR FINE AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB FOUR OH
NINE BY SENATOR WILK. ILLEGAL
DUMPING HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB
FIVE EIGHTY SENATOR WILK
PROBATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE. S.
B. C. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE THIS IS
AN OMNIBUS BILL. DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL RELATED
TO THE DENTIST SIX. LICENSURE
EXAMS EXTEND THE REQUIREMENT
FOR LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
COMMITTEE TO CONDUCT BACKGROUND
CHECKS. THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. YES OF COURSE. GRAYSON
RIGHT WE WILL SEND THE OFFICIAL
RESULTS THERE WERE SOME CHANGES
AS WE WENT ALONG SAID WE'LL
SEND OFFICIAL RESULTS. TO YOUR
EMAILS LATER I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR GREAT
ATTENTION TO THIS AND OF COURSE
I WANT MY COACH. EVERYTHING
WILL BE POSTED ONLINE AS WELL.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR ASSEMBLY.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.